[Music]
foreign
in the early days of quantum mechanics a
quasi-probability distribution also
known as a qpd Bridges between classical
and quantum theories there's this guy
named Eugene wigner who around 1932
published his paper on the quantum
Corrections of thermodynamic
equilibriums which introduces the wigner
function what's notable here is that
both position and momentum appear in
this analog to the wave function when
ordinarily you choose to work in the
so-called momentum space or position
space but not both to better grasp the
concept think of quasi-probability
distributions as maps that encode
Quantum features into classical-like
probability distributions whenever you
hear the suffix light you should
immediately be skeptical as space like
is in space and time-like isn't the same
thing as time in this instance classical
like isn't classical there's something
called the kalmogorov axioms of
probability and some of them are relaxed
in these quasi-probability distributions
for instance you're allowed negative
probabilities they also don't have to
sum up to one and doing so with the
wigner function reveals some of the more
peculiar aspects of quantum theory like
superposition and entanglement the
development of qpds expanded with the
globber sadarshan p representation
introduced by sadarshan in 1963 and
refined by glauber and husumi's Q
representation in 1940. qpds play a
crucial role in Quantum tomography which
allow us to reconstruct and characterize
unknown Quantum States they also
maintain their invariance under
simplexic Transformations preserving the
structure of Base based Dynamics you can
think of this as preserving the areas of
parallelograms formed by vectors in
Phase space nowadays qpds have ventured
beyond the quantum realm inspiring
advancements in machine learning and
artificial intelligence this is called
Quantum machine learning and while it's
in its infancy it may be that the next
breakthrough in lower in compute lies
with these kernel methods and Quantum
variational encoders by leveraging qpds
in place of density matrices researchers
gained the ability to study Quantum
processes with reduced computational
complexity for instance qpds have been
employed to create Quantum inspired
optimization algorithms like the quantum
inspired genetic algorithm qga which
incorporates Quantum superposition to
enhance search and optimization
processes Quantum variational
autoencoders can be used for tasks such
as Quantum States compression and
Quantum generative models also Quantum
error mitigation the whole point of this
is that there are new techniques being
developed daily and unlike the
incremental change of the past there's a
probability a low one but it's non-zero
that one of these will remarkably and
irrevocably change the landscape of
Technology
foreign
so generalizations are important for
instance Spin and gr saw general
relativity is known to be the only
Theory that's consistent with being low
rents and variants having an interaction
and being spin to something called spin
two this means if you have a field and
it's spin two and it's not free so
there's interactions and it's Lorenz
invariant and general relativity pops
out meaning you get it as a result now
this interacting aspect is important
because if you have a scalar so if you
have a spin zero field then what happens
is it couples to the trace of the energy
momentum tensor because there's nothing
else for it to couple to and it turns
out that does reproduce Newton's law of
gravity however as soon as you add an
interacting relativistic matter then you
don't get that light bends so then you
think well let's generalize it to spin
one and then there are some problems
there and you think well let's
generalize it to spin three and above
and there's some no-go theorems by
Weinberg there by the way the problem
with spin one is that masses will repel
for the same reason that in
electromagnetism that if you have same
charges they repel okay other than just
a handful of papers it seems like we've
covered all the necessary ground and
when there's more room to be covered
I'll cover it spasmodically throughout
the podcast there will be links to the
papers and to the other Concepts that
are explored in the description most of
the prep work for this conversation
seems to be out of the way so now let's
introduce Daniel schmuttenberger you
just watched a clip from the theories of
everything channel for the full video
and all its magnificence then click here
and if you'd like to see more then
subscribe enjoy